دراسه صادمه في المانيا نعم صادمه وفي
المانيا وهذا ليس وصفي بل وصف منظمات
حقوقيه لاستطلاع وجد ان ثلث الرجال
الالمانيين يقبلون العنف ضد المراه
والاكثر دهشه في هذا البلد الاوروبي ان
34% منهم اقروا بممارستهم العنف ضد النساء
سابقا
الاستطلاع اجرته منظمه
لرجال تتراوح اعمارهم بين 18 و 35 عاما
قالوا انهم يقبلون ان تفلت ايديهم او تخرج
عن السيطره احيانا خلال الشجار مع شركاتهم
او زوجاتهم وهو مشكله كبيره في وجه
المساواه ويجب ان يتغير هذا سريعا بحسب
ناشطين
ربما هذا ما يفسر ايضا ما اشارت اليه
بيانات الشرطه الى تعرض 115 الف امراه في
المانيا للعنف من الشريك عام 2021 بل تتسم
المانيا ايضا بواحده من اعلى معدلات قتل
الاناث في اوروبا بحسب الشرطه
[موسيقى]